[Musique]
en revanche les fenêtres mais la gamme
ali
[Musique]
agent ward qu'est ce qui s'est passé
gesca dans ma voiture et le monde entier
qui me regardent premier agent de police
orc de notre nation que pas [ __ ] ma
retraite en l'air et tu mets vite le
coup d'épée pourquoi ces désordres qui
joue le rôle des méchants de l'histoire
on a répondu à une alerte 95 tapage
nocturne
on a essuyé des tirs tout va bien ça va
pas trop de balles en jeu celui avec
lequel je suis né et toi ça va être ou
même une fusillade durant sa gêne en toi
d'un kg est magique ce truc là c'est
comme une bombe atomique
quel sens tout et veut les choses ont
vraiment commencé à dégénérer à partir
de là la magie ne fait que tuer et
détruire le diable arrive
on doit protéger la baguette j'ai besoin
de savoir si cas implique avant tout ou
peu nord qu'avant tout il est temps que
ça s'arrête
rien à [ __ ] j'ai envie de mourir ouais
on y va on va crever dans une [ __ ] de
fusillades de barani champ
dix ans de prison
tu as vraiment de main gauche mais toi
tu as les deux autres
est-ce qu'on est un mythe je crois qu'on
devrait plutôt passer le temps à essayer
de survivre c'est correct
si on y arrive
on se souviendra nous en héros
donc j'ai besoin que toi oui toi et ta
[ __ ] de grosses gueules de shrek à la
con vous retournez chez vous vend
vionnaz d'accord